[Musique]
je vous présente tout ce que j'ai le
reste je les données parce que il en
faut peu pour être heureux vraiment très
peu pour être heureux et sa gelée
compris parce que je suis vraiment très
heureux en ce moment je me suis mis au
service d'une grande cause
je fais ce que j'aime faire et ce que je
sais faire le mieux je vais vous
raconter comment j'en suis arrivée là ça
s'est passé en trois étapes
l'apprentissage la prise de conscience
et la réalisation l'apprentissage
honnêtement ça a été long parce que j'ai
fait le concours vétérinaire après j'ai
fait six ans d'études
j'exerçais six mois puis après j'ai
décidé de faire le concours des écoles
de commerce et je suis allé à le scp
l'école supérieure de commerce de paris
donc d'un côté on peut penser que j'ai
tout réussi et de l'autre que j'ai fait
n'importe quoi mais j'aime bien faire
travailler les deux côtés de mon cerveau
le droit qui est créatif imaginatif
celui qu'on n'utilise pas assez et le
gauche logique rationnelle
j'aime bien faire travailler mon
intuition avec ma raison pour prendre
tous les points de vue complexifier les
choses et après les synthétiser comme la
théorie n'est rien sans la pratique à le
scp j'ai lancé mon collectif d'artistes
on a commencé à travailler pour la
publicité
la publicité rapporter de l'argent et ça
permettait de financer le collectif
d'artistes on a travaillé pour toutes
les grandes agences de publicité puis
après tout les grandes marques
on a même eu le grand prix du festival
de cannes de la publicité on produisait
de plus en plus à la fin produisait
entre 200 et 300 production publicitaire
ou événementielles on était vraiment
dans la surconsommation et c'est là qu'a
eu lieu la prise de conscience
on mettait au service des marques qui
pousse à la surconsommation des artistes
qui sont des êtres sensibles et en fait
aujourd'hui on est le jour du
dépassement le 3 mai en france au niveau
international
c'est le 8 août c'est à dire qu'on
consomme 1,7 planète par an ce que la
planète produit en un an on le consomme
1,7 fois et tous les ans est de plus en
plus rapide
donc on puise dans nos ressources et nos
ressources sont pas infinies mais pire
que ça on est dans la sixième extinction
de masse
hubert reeves nous l'annoncent tout le
temps et de nombreux scientifiques sont
avec lui
50% des espèces animales ont disparu en
moins de 40 ans il est temps qu'on se
réveille il est temps que l'humanité
prennent conscience il faut pas lutter
contre le système parce que ce que tu
combats tu le nourris watch résiste
persiste nous dit car lyon donc il faut
le transformer de l'intérieur
il faut l'améliorer tous ensemble et en
fait c'est ça qui est fantastique c'est
tout d'un coup on peut faire ce que tout
le monde a toujours rêvé de faire
vous avez tous rêvé de changer le monde
émincer le moment il ya plein de gens
qui sont en train de le faire je suis
sûr que dans la salle y en a déjà qui
sont à l'action tous les jours il ya des
associations il ya des entreprises
il ya des gens qui font tout seuls qu
importe la méthode
il est temps d'améliorer le monde
j'ai réfléchi j'ai tout arrêté j'ai
laissé la spen et factory à mon frère
qui s'en occupe très bien d'ailleurs
et puis je suis devenu végétarien
parce que quand même plus de 1000
milliards d'animaux massacrés par an
pour la consommation humaine
ça fait beaucoup et puis je suis devenu
minimaliste pour arrêter cette
surconsommation et nomade aussi
pour rencontrer des gens qui ont des
solutions et ça m'a permis de rencontrer
jane goudal alors notre rencontre à être
est assez folklorique franchement parce
que j'ai eu son contact par un ami qui
s'appelle pierre quintard que je
remercie je les appelais elle est très
occupée donc elle m'a donné rendez vous
dans huit heures pour un quart d'heure à
l'aéroport de heathrow
donc je me suis dépêché j'ai pris ma
valise le métro le train le taxi et je
suis arrivé 7 minutes en retard
j'avais plus cuit minutes mais en fait
ça s'est très bien passé on est resté
une heure ensemble on a parlé de ce
qu'elle faisait des possibilités qu'on
avait travaillé ensemble ça va donner ce
que vous montrez après jane goudal à 84
ans ça fait des années qu'elle étudie
les chimpanzés
elle a eu plusieurs pays et jeudi à
cambridge pour ça et elle a plus de
quinze légion d'honneur dans différents
pays
elle est ambassadrice de la paix aux
nations unies
et surtout elles voyagent plus de 250
jours par an pour amener partout le même
message la même cause
l'humanité la nature et les animaux
elle sait qu'on est tous unis
interconnecté qu'on est tous reliés un
seul et même écosystème et un niveau
métaphysique une seule et même
conscience partout elle dit la même
chose à tout le monde chacun peut et
doit faire quelque chose pour améliorer
le monde
ok je suis devenu végétarien minimaliste
mais ça suffit pas qu'est-ce que je peux
faire
franchement je sais pas quoi faire
qu'est-ce que je peux faire
cette question je me la supposée mille
fois j'ai douté j'ai cherché je suis
sorti de ma zone de confort
et puis un jour
j'ai tout écrit tout ce que j'avais
faire toutes mes compétences sur une
feuille et je me suis dit je vais tout
mettre au service d'une seule et même
cause améliorer le monde alors ça peut
paraître prétentieux mais c'est un peu
comme un rêve
et en plus il ya une urgence est là
l'énorme buzz le de toute ma vie
cette assemblée e reka la petite
illuminations parce que c'est ça en fait
toute votre vie vous faites des choses
vous avez l'impression que ça sert à
rien vous apprenez des trucs vous avez
vraiment l'impression ne s'en
serviraient jamais et puis tout d'un
coup vous regarder tranquillement en
vous vous prenez du recul globalement
holistique mans tout ce que vous avez
fait vous a fait évoluer tout ce que
vous avez appris peut vous servir
ainsi c'est votre voix votre mission
c'est ce qu'il ya de plus proche de vous
c'est ce que vous rêvez de faire que
vous devez suivre
c'est la réalisation de soi donc ma
réalisation c'est walt d'immersion oil
d'immersion c'est la première réserve
virtuelle au monde
je vais vous téléporter au milieu des
animaux sauvages
je vais me servir des nouvelles
technologies et de la beauté de la
nature pour vous émerveiller
je vais vous ouvrir le coeur et y
déposer de l'amour je vais créer de
l'empathie chez vous pour que vous ayez
envie de protéger la nature et les
animaux
et ça ça va permettre de financer des
vrais réserve parce qu'il faut passer du
virtuel au réel donc oil d'immersion
vous mettez votre casque de réalité
virtuelle
bon ok
vous avez l'air un peu bizarre
mais tout d'un coup vous êtes entourés
par des girafes
vous êtes carrément en dessous dans des
positions incroyables au plus proche des
animaux
vous voulez avec les flamands roses il y
en a tout autour de vous et en fait ce
qui est extraordinaire c'est de voir que
les gens se connectent tout d'un coup à
la nature à quelque chose de beau à
quelque chose de sauvage
il faut faire un voyage qu'il est
impossible de faire
en réalité vous allez découvrir des
endroits magnifiques des sols n'ont
foulé par l'être humain et être
totalement immergé dans un monde sauvage
ça va lentement là c'est un teaser mais
dans l'expérience vous êtes tranquille
vous avez les sons de la nature vous
êtes apaisée en fait réellement on vous
donne de l'amour est normalement quand
vous recevez de l'amour vous avez envie
d'en redistribuer
vous avez envie de protéger cette nature
et vous m avec ces animaux pour
développer des réserves et permettre aux
suivants de continuer d'admirer les
beautés de notre planète
voilà ce que c'est moi le d'immersion
c'est d'être entouré par les flamands
roses d'en voir partout de croiser des
jaguars de voir des lions bref tout ce
qui pourrait disparaître
c'est mon i qui gagnent le et qui gaye
c'est un symbole japonais c'est de
rassembler tout ce qu'on est
pour arriver à sa mission j'ai donc
rassemblé ce que je sais faire
la production film événementiel dea
nouvelles technologies ce que j'aime
faire la partie vétérinaires les animaux
la communication le buzz
ce pourquoi je suis payé la partie
business gestion financement et ce dont
le monde a besoin la grande cause ce
qu'il faut améliorer
on va créer en fait des parcs
d'attraction vous pourrez vous connecter
à la nature à paris en chine à montréal
à los angeles à londres
mais plus important on va développer des
réserves on est déjà en train de voir en
thaïlande et en tanzanie
mais il y en a pour tout le monde en
fait
et c'est ça qui est extraordinaire c'est
que je connais des gens qui étaient des
mercenaires
donc c'est pas forcément des gens bien
au départ à 1 et maintenant ils sont mis
à la lutte anti braconnage des massaï
qui avant chasser les lions et qui
maintenant les protège l'ensemble de
l'humanité est en train de prendre
conscience est en train de changer
est en train d'essayer d'améliorer les
choses et si vous savez pas quoi faire
il ya plein d'associations jane goodall
a développé une association qui
s'appelle route ancients y en a plus de
110000 à travers le monde et vous donne
des missions et je connais un financier
par exemple ça lui prend pas beaucoup de
temps
une fois par mois il va planter des
arbres mais en fait ça le
de l'intérieur il prend conscience et en
parlent autour de lui il est devenu
végétarien y rayonne
il est heureux parce qu'en fait c'est ça
le bonheur
c'est d'avoir l'impression que ce qu'on
fait ce qu'on né sert à quelque chose
est utile et valoriser en fait il en
faut peu pour être heureux vraiment très
peu pour être heureux il faut se
satisfaire d'une nécessaire et le
problème c'est qu'on confond le bonheur
avec le plaisir le plaisir c'est ce que
vous vend la société de consommation
c'est ce toujours plus le plaisir c'est
addictif
c'est de la dopamine il en faut toujours
plus toujours plus vite
le bonheur c'est plus basé sur les
endorphines
c'est un inhibiteur savent calme ça vous
apaise la dopamine
il en faut de plus en plus et ça donne
de moins en moins de résultats les
endorphines
il en faut de moins en moins et ça vous
calme donc pourquoi se gâcher la vie en
fait il faut prendre le temps il faut
regarder en soit ce qu on est ce qu'on
aime il faut trouver quelque chose qui
est utile qui fait sens et que vous
aimez faire et à ce moment-là ça vous
rend heureux et ça va améliorer le monde
ou alors vous faites complètement le
contraire vous améliorer le monde et ça
va vous rendre heureux
mais surtout il faut pas oublier que
chacun peut et doit améliorer le monde
et on doit le faire tous ensemble et
donc comme j'aime bien les défis
je sais qu'en france on n'aime pas trop
chanter donc je vais vous demander
quelque chose c'est de chanter avec moi
2 3 il en faut peu pour être heureux
vraiment très peu pour être heureux il
faut se satisfaire d'une nécessaire je
vous remercie beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]